[Music]
Clen there's only so many things left to
do I walk out and I see a list I'm like
can I say keep cooling my babies no what
I've done is I I've spent 20 years
trying to claim everything by randomly
every night doing something stupid and
arbitrary so that then I can sit back
and say I did that in 95 I came out and
put on a mining helmet and went aoy M
mies that's taken like I can just tag
everything so you're boxed in man that's
right nowhere to go there's nothing to
do though I didn't think of
this
this I love this this is the this is the
Amish R2-D2 right
here
R2 Amish lightsabers are just brooms
yeah they're just brooms they have no
hars there's nothing they can accomplish
Obi-Wan actly the same except it's a
he's the same yeah OB one's the same
he's the same guy he's just
grumpier